a good majority of movies that come out
all right you pretty much know
everything you're going to see in the
movie by the first 10 or 20 minutes now
that's not a story a story is something
that constantly unfolds I'm not talking
about like this quick left turn or a
quick right turn or a big surprise I'm
talking about it unfolds most movies
that you see now I mean that used to be
the thing about America was the fact
that Hollywood freaking America
Hollywood used to that's what we did
better than anybody else in the world we
told a really good story you know Europe
was where you had character-based films
or mood-based films but America we told
the story we're the worst at it now as
far as I'm concerned I'm telling a story
we don't tell a story we tell a
situation most of the movies that you
see nowadays and I'm not a Hollywood
bastard because enough good movies come
out of the Hollywood System every year
to justify as existence yeah but you
don't believe in a linear storytelling
well it's not you know it's not so much
I don't believe in it it's the situation
too um well it's no it's it's not the
fact that I'm like I'm this big Crusade
against linear storytelling all right
but it's the thing is it's not the only
game in town